George Lucas and George R.R Martin the
two biggest Titans of fantasy and
science fiction both Martin and Lucas
have created rich and complex universes
that have captured the hearts and
imaginations of millions of fans around
the world but the question is which did
it better Star Wars or Game of Thrones
in this video we'll be comparing the two
creators on these seven completely
objective and dare I say scientific
factors George R.R Martin is best known
for his A Song Of Ice And Fire series
which was adapted into the wildly
popular HBO series Game of Thrones
Martin's series is set in a medieval
inspired fantasy world filled with
political Intrigue epic battles and
Larger than Life characters George Lucas
on the other hand is the creator of the
Star Wars franchise Lucas's universe is
set in a galaxy far far away and
features Jedi Knights evil Sith Lords
and epic Space Battles although both
creators worked on other franchises such
as Indiana Jones and Elden ring for the
sake of this video we'll just be looking
at the Star Wars franchise for Lucas's
body of work and The Game of Thrones
franchise for Martin's body of work
first let's take a look at the worlds
that Martin and Lucas have created
Martin's A Song Of Ice And Fire series
is primarily set in Westeros a continent
filled with Seven Kingdoms each with its
own unique culture and history Martin's
world is grounded in realism with the
conflicts and power struggles between
the kingdoms feeling all too familiar to
readers Martin's characters are also
incredibly complex and nuanced with many
of them struggling with moral ambiguity
and the cost of power Lucas's Star Wars
Universe on the other hand is set in a
galaxy far far away and is heavily
influenced by the Epic Fantasy stories
of the past the Jedi Knights and Sith
Lords of Star Wars are stuff of Legend
and Lucas's world is filled with all
manner of strange and exotic creatures
in technology Lucas's universe is also
heavily steeped in mysticism with the
force playing a central role in the
stories both Martin and Lucas have
created worlds that are incredibly rich
and detailed but in very different ways
Martin's World feels more grounded in
reality while Lucas's is more
Fantastical both of them have created
worlds that are easy to get lost in and
that's what makes them so enjoyable to
read and watch on their world's level of
complexity and depth I think Star Wars
and Game of Thrones are just about even
so for this first round they'll both get
a point next let's take a look at the
characters that populate these worlds
Martin's characters are some of the most
complex and well-developed in fantasy
literature characters like Tyrion
Lannister and Daenerys Targaryen are
fully realized individuals with their
own unique motivations and desires
Martin's characters often find
themselves in morally complex situations
and their choices and actions have real
consequences Lucas's characters while
not as complex as Martin's are still
well developed and interesting
characters like Luke Skywalker and Darth
Vader are iconic and have become
ingrained in pop culture Lucas's
characters also find themselves in
morally complex situations but their
choices and actions tend to be more
black and white both Martin and Lucas
have created memorable and iconic
characters but Martin's characters are
more complex and nuanced so Martin's
Game of Thrones gets the point in this
category now let's take a look at
writing Styles Martin is a master of
character development and his writing is
also known for its intricate World
building and political Intrigue with
conflicts and power struggles between
the kingdoms feeling all too familiar to
readers on the other hand Lucas's
writing is known for its more
family-friendly stories with iconic
characters and a richly detailed World
Martin's stories are more complex and
mature while Lucas's stories are more
action-packed and fun Martin's stories
often explore the darker side of human
nature while Lucas's often have a more
uplifting and hopeful message when it
comes to the quality of writing both
authors have their own unique styles
that have been praised by critics and
loved by fans in terms of literary merit
Martin's writing is considered to be
more critically acclaimed and his Works
have won several Awards and have been
nominated for many more Lucas's writing
is popular and considered more
mainstream his Works have also been
awarded but in a different way with more
focus on technical achievement and
Commercial Success altogether though I'd
say Martin has a better writing style
mostly because of the Fantastic dialogue
he brings in his writing I mean just
compare this I don't like sand to this
do I have my mind and the mind needs
books like a sword needs a wet stone
so the point goes to Martin for writing
and it definitely influences the next
category stories Martin's series is a
political epic that explores the power
of nature in the cost of ambition his
stories are often brutal and unflinching
and they often have a bleak and cynical
tone Lucas's Star Wars stories on the
other hand are more traditional Heroes
Journey Tales the stories are filled
with action and adventure and are often
more optimistic in tone Martin's stories
are more complex and mature while
Lucas's are more simplistic and at times
a bit childish while the audience would
certainly impact which story type they'd
like more I'd still say Lucas gets the
point in this category due to the
universal nature of his stories that
almost anyone can understand and
appreciate next up is the level of
realism and escapism Martin's writing is
known for its realism with conflicts and
power struggles between Lords and
kingdoms that feel Dynamic and lived in
Martin's characters are also incredibly
complex and nuanced after reading his
books you feel like you really know his
characters they're grounded in realism
and that contributes heavily to the
story George Lucas on the other hand is
known for his story's escapism set in a
galaxy far far away featuring Jedi
Knights and epic Space Battles you know
who the heroes and villains are right
away you know that good can and will win
the day but you're so drawn in by the
Fantastical setting and epic story that
you can't help but watch to its climax
both Martin and Lucas have created
stories that are engaging and
entertaining but in very different ways
I'd say because of this the two are
pretty evenly mashed in this category so
they'll each get a point both Martin and
Lucas have created stories that are
beloved by millions of fans around the
world but our next category asks which
author's work is more impactful in
today's culture first let's take a look
at Martin's cultural prevalence The A
Song Of Ice And Fire series and its
adaptation Game of Thrones has become a
cultural Phenomenon with millions of
fans around the world and a vast array
of merchandise and spin-offs Martin's
work has also been widely studied and
analyzed in academic circles and it's
been the subject of numerous essays and
books the HBO series adaptation became
one of the most watched and critically
acclaimed Series in television history
and the books have sold millions of
copies on the other hand Lucas's Star
Wars franchise has been a cultural
phenomenon for decades with millions and
maybe even billions of fans around the
world Lucas's work has also been widely
studied in academic circles but it's
more known for its commercial success
and impact on the film industry and pop
culture the franchise has generated
billions of dollars in revenue and has
become one of the most successful and
recognizable franchises in the world
both Martin and Lucas have created
stories that are beloved by millions of
fans but Lucas's work is considered more
prevalent in our culture today with more
commercial success and impact on the
film industry and pop culture Martin's
work is also considered a cultural
phenomenon but more based on its
literary merit and critical Acclaim so
Lucas gets the point in this category
lastly let's compare the futures of the
two franchises George R.R Martin's A
Song Of Ice And Fire series has already
spawned a hugely successful television
adaptation in Game of Thrones and
several spin-offs such as House of
Dragon however Martin is still in the
process of writing the final books in
the series and the future of the
franchise is uncertain Martin has stated
that the final books will be longer than
the previous ones and will have more
characters and story lines fans are
eagerly awaiting the final books but
with no release date in sight it's
unclear when or if they'll ever be
published on the other hand George
Lucas's Star Wars franchise has a very
clear future lucasfilm the company that
Lucas founded and sold to Disney has
announced a number of upcoming projects
including several new films television
series and other spin-offs the franchise
has generated billions of dollars in
revenue and has become one of the most
successful and recognizable franchises
in the world and Disney plans to
continue to release new Star Wars
content for years to come the few future
of Martin's franchise is uncertain with
no release date in sight for the final
books while Lucas's franchise has a very
clear future with a number of upcoming
projects and new content planned
therefore Lucas takes the point in this
category all in all though who did it
better both George RR Martin and George
Lucas have created worlds characters and
stories that are beloved by millions of
fans Martin's work is more complex and
mature while Lucas's work is more
action-packed and fun both creators have
built universes that are easy to get
lost in and that's what makes them so
enjoyable to read and watch if your
basic it off this point system where I
arbitrarily assigned Point values to
things I think are important than George
Lucas one but at the end of the day it's
all about personal preference it's hard
to say who did it better some people may
prefer Martin's more complex and mature
stories While others may prefer Lucas's
more family-friendly stories I for one
love them both and I can't wait to see
where these two franchises go next
[Music]